euh se produit en deux phases bien
qu'il y aura une capture douce suivie d'
une
capture dure et ce que cette capture dure
signifie, c'est que
12 crochets physiques connecteront
le dragon à la station spatiale de
superbes vues dragon à seulement six mètres alors
que la station et le dragon volent en tandem
263 milles terrestres au-dessus de l'océan indien sud
en arrière-plan cinq mètres
nous sommes à cinq mètres et la
copie de fermeture à cinq mètres
nous commençons à voir le détail sur le dragon
là-bas alors
qu'il se rapproche de l'amarrage
c'est juste deux mètres et demi 30
secondes
mains d'équipage  le point de départ a été appelé
dragon spacex sur la grande boucle la capture douce a
confirmé une
excellente nouvelle avec cet appel que la
capture douce est
confirmée
c'est vrai que l'heure de capture douce 208
h, heure du Pacifique 408 h,
station orientale et dragon connecté 264 milles terrestres au
-dessus de l'océan indien sud
effort connecté à la
station spatiale internationale pour la deuxième fois
il reste encore quelques étapes à accomplir
avant que le dragon ne soit solidement attaché
dragon spacex sur  la
rétraction de l'anneau de capture douce de la grande boucle est en cours,
c'est bien la rétraction de l'anneau se
produit
, la rétraction de l'anneau se produit comme prévu
et après que l'anneau se rétracte, 12 crochets
se verrouilleront
six à la fois pour effectuer une capture dure
et nous accouplerons officiellement
euh dragon à l'international  la
station spatiale a
eu cette vue vraiment impressionnante du dragon
car elle est connectée au port
actuellement euh fait des progrès sur
la capture dure de
vous